Brian is on the line Brian's in
Pittsburgh
how are you Brian I'm good how about you
do better than I deserve what's up good
question
I'm I currently have my degree in
business good bye out of your address
and I'm looking to make a career change
into being a teacher and in order to do
that I would have to go back to school
and get a graduate degree and that would
require me taking out about $20,000 in
debt and kind of want your advice I'm
kind of a little iffy about that yeah
well I've been doing this show almost 30
years and I've never till told anyone to
borrow money yeah with the exception of
a mortgage so probably not going to
start today so how can we in other words
because I found the best way for you to
prosper and the best way to have a
quality life is to get out and stay out
of debt so then the question starts to
be if I'm in your shoes how can I do
this without that so what's your car
worth about nine thousand good okay and
do you own your home
I do not okay you're renting no I
currently I'm 25 I currently with us
live with my parents
okay cool all right she got no overhead
what's your income I currently just
moved back from abroad so right now
probably 20,000 a year what were you
doing when you were abroad I took some
time off from the corporate world and I
was studying I went to a Chris and Bible
School
oh good good for you okay yeah and and
so on you've spent a lot of time in
school chasing different things then
yeah okay there's nothing wrong with
that
I just don't want you every time you
have a
a dissatisfaction was something to
immediately equate the the solution to
that dissatisfaction to be go get
another degree because you're gonna be
broke and heavily educated at the end of
that story
and we don't want to go that route it's
not to say you shouldn't change
directions ever and you shouldn't go
back and get a different degree ever so
I have a son who's 26 if this was a
conversation with him I would want to
know more obviously and I would know
more because he's my son
but with what I know about your story I
would tell you to go get a really really
good job and work it for two years and
pile up the money to do this mmm
possibility by then that you would be
very very sure that you want to be a
teacher or maybe you would find that
there's some ways you can teach in the
business world that scratches your
teaching itch you certainly can do any
of these things as a ministry business
can be a ministry teaching can be a
ministry it's the way you look at it and
the way you say this serve god I'm gonna
serve people this way and I'm on be a
you know a fabulous in classroom teacher
I'm going to be a world-class corporate
trainer and teach people with the level
of excellence and that's my ministry you
can be in the formal a pastoral ministry
side of things since you did some Bibles
that some Bible School that's why I'm
weaving all that in but yeah I would
just tell you let's go get a job and
let's build a life go make some money
and for two years and you'll you'll make
you can y'all be able to save twenty
thousand dollars in two years pretty
easy if you go get a real job now you're
right now you're just working you know
some kind of I just got back from
overseas job but I'm talking about a
real job and you go take your business
degree get into the marketplace land
something making 30 40 50 thousand you
know get you an apartment rent move out
on your own pay your bills save twenty
thousand bucks and then when you're
looking at that twenty thousand dollars
as a pile on the cash in the mill the
table you start asking yourself do I
want to be a teacher
that bad and it might change your
direction it might be that you want to
be but then you'll have the cash to pay
for
hey that's what I would do this is the
Dave Ramsey show